It's always one heartbreak after another.
There are people who just love the drama of relationship, but I don't think anyone specifically
pines for heartbreak.
I mean, I always give my best.
I try to be more than fair as a girlfriend, but sometimes I get nit thinking that somehow
it's all my fault.
I just can't wrap my head around how that could be possible.
There are times like this where I try to think back to the start of my love life, starting
with my first love and first loss.
Maybe try to compare and see where I went wrong this time.
It started back in early college.
I was studying to become a fashion designer if you can believe that.
I wasn't as, well, deliciously brazen in my outfit choices as I am now.
A quiet, much-to-overlook girl who never got invited to parties.
Their loss, though I imagine I had more fun sewing, crafting and anything else a grandma
would do with spare time.
An old soul people would call me.
I was content in my own quiet.
That was until I met my first love.
I don't know what he saw in me, but he was the one to make the first move.
Even before I had the mind addressed to attract the male gaze.
Here I was more of an ominous sheet ghost, whatever the reason.
Here was a man who takes charge where he needs to.
He was a dirty, rabid-looking man who stank a booze and oozed failure and degeneracy.
In retrospect, in our first meeting, he was a bit more pushy than I'm used to nowadays.
It's best to understand that the pillar of a strong relationship is setting up boundaries
and it's best to do it as soon as possible.
Putting your foot down, telling your partner what's what is a risk you have to take.
It was because of that I remembered that I always keep my fabric scissors with me.
When you interact with your partner honestly, if the love is true, they can feel your intent.
That's when the honest, purest part of them comes out.
My favorite stage in all of my relationships.
It was like he was a completely different person from his introduction.
He showed me his true self, a part men are taught to hide away, the soft, sweet, vulnerable
man inside.
I mean, how could I not fall for him?
I don't think I have a particular type per se, but a man who expresses his emotions in
such a delicious way, that's something I couldn't resist.
I just had to have him.
I had brought him to an old shed my family owns, the best I could do at the time, but
together our love can make it a home.
You see, good relationships are built on compromise, and I, and compromise I did.
I gave that man everything, everything he could ever want.
I bathed him, fed him, cared for him, gave myself to him.
The time we spent, I gave him all I had to give.
That's what relationships are, I give and take.
You give your all to someone, and you expect them to do the same for you.
And you know what he does?
Just runs away, out of the blue.
No talking, no indication anything is wrong, just leaves.
I couldn't understand.
I was high off of my affection for him, and I thought he was the same.
But I had to hold in my sadness.
I, for one, am better than leaving without a word.
Relationships, no matter what, should be ended properly.
After all, sometimes relationships don't work out for reasons you don't understand.
But where there was true love, there can be a lot of fun to be had.
Right?
Before cutting ties.
After that, it was fling after fling, a new love here and there, all ending the same way.
I hate having to be the nice one in the relationship.
It can't be my fault.
I guess men will take any chance to abuse your kindness.
Now the break of songs and the radio start to make sense, and the sweetest sugars are
now as bitter as vinegar.
It's times like this when I think I'm about to give up on love entirely, but as they say,
time heals all wounds.
After that, it feels like the very first time.